[Music]
a sporter and activity permanently
associated with
you is
unbelievable
[Music]
text mom we are actually going to get
there at 11 30. your message to mom says
we are actually going to get there at 11
30.
ready to send it yes
okay it's set
thanks homie
[Music]
oh they actually might be home
i see their car
it was a very rambunctious very active
kid
who started getting in trouble from the
moment he learned to crawl he
particularly liked
all things electrical including
electrical outlets his memory is very
very good
and when he stay with us in virginia we
stroll around these neighborhood
neighborhoods and so on and he started
to remember all the cars yeah he'd been
fascinated
and he remembered all of them the first
person who taught me how to play chess
was my grandfather he taught me when i
was younger he played and my parents
were deciding
which after school class to sign me up
for
my mom said they should put me into
chess and my dad said they should put me
into art because i was a crazy kid there
was no way i was gonna sit still until
the age of four levy knew only one
language and that was a russian so his
first language is russia
chess is a very russian tradition
pretty much everybody in russia plays
chess at least at some point it's like
you know baseball for americans i played
my first tournament when i was seven
and it was basically after i had beaten
my dad like i played my dad all the time
and he said all right enough playing me
you're gonna go to this chess club and
play a tournament and i and i crushed
the tournament so i was super happy
super excited got a trophy and i met
susan polgar who's one of the most
accomplished female chess players of all
time
players of all time period
and
that was it i basically played chess all
the time
[Music]
in 2008 in february
i crossed 2000 at a chess tournament and
i was 12. which back then was a pretty
big accomplishment i was like top five
in the country for my age for a couple
months i was number two
but i stayed the same level for three
years and i decided that it was better
to just not struggle with it and try to
overcome and it just quit i saw no
future in chess
and that's probably around the time in
life you need someone to sit you down
smack you upside the head and say this
is the only thing that you are good at
idiot and i came back to the game
because
uh i had a friend who who played chess
and
i picked up a book that he had that he
really liked and it it's the same
opening that i play
to this day the defense the carl khan
defense
and when i was about 15 years old i came
back consistently and i started playing
like more tournaments
uh frankly i knew that he was quick he
he did quick quick thinking and he went
to economics program
at barrow college versus amazing college
so he had a pretty good education
statistics um economics
my kind of
vision of him was like he would join
some sort of a boutique trading company
and become like an arbitrage trader or
you know some some kind of exotic trader
because he has a great
inclination for pro
pattern recognition
i have
master's degree he has a degree in
physics so in our opinion even before
with our children it was so what what
our children supposed to do or something
something and technical fail
they were really worried that
if you didn't go your typical route you
know college degree bachelors in
economics work at a bank
um continue working at a bank work in a
different bank you know climb up you
know
what is the career path then if you
don't follow that everything worked
miraculously i'm very happy for him i'm
still concerned about his long-term
perspectives i don't know for how long
can you can be a youtuber on the top of
the chart one day you will be beaten
and what do you do
oh
i met lucy for the first time in
november 2015 actually uh and the story
is that i
i met her she was the sweet maid of
someone i had gone on a couple dates
with
our first date in 2015 went so poorly
because i didn't understand
a sense of humor and i thought it was
great i thought it was a fun date in
november or december 2015 and she hated
me
so that was very inconvenient
and we ended up not seeing each other
again um fast forward a couple years you
know on these on these apps that people
meet themselves uh meet each other on
now and um in 2017 and i saw her and i
still had her phone number so i texted
her and he goes do you think after three
years four years i don't know i can
finally get that second date
um
and i think i just responded why do you
still have my number
but i still had your number so so what
[Music]
yeah i grew a lot as a person
uh through meeting lucy and i would be
nowhere near uh the person or
personality that i am today uh if it
wouldn't be for her um
if he takes back
i'll just take
and then
i'll trade bishops or something like
that and i'll like win a pawn
but if i take and he takes here
i can just
wait hold on if my knight takes
and
he takes my bishop like this
i can go here
he'll take
and then i take
looks good to me
in 2018 in february is when i started my
online content
the twitch
and back then it was a
wild time twitch was
me coming home after a long day of
teaching
and then just streaming blitz games
drinking beer and playing rock music on
my phone from 9 pm until 4 in the
morning
there were a couple of events in my life
in january february 2020 that
i could have ended up with nothing i
mean no relationship no
uh no program potentially
and
i decided to make a very conscious
effort to change a few things
and start streaming
more
the first contract i ever signed with
just.com to be exclusive was actually
like right when the pandemic started and
i had no youtube presence and i had no
no following
i wanted to build around the beginner
and early intermediate audience because
the content for them was not super
accessible so if i was making them laugh
or teaching them something or both
that's what i thought would be
successful
i want to say it doesn't matter but it's
a computer it scares me g4
computers also are like very
cold-blooded no that must be a bad move
that must be what even is that that
doesn't even address what i'm trying to
do on the side of the board stop it
computer i'm gonna pin you
it's just a lot of fun i really enjoy
doing it i like scheduling the content
and i like to
come up with ideas this video is gonna
be kind of
difficult to do uh because it's
[Music]
eight of magnus's like best endgame
wins oh wow he played him twice
[Music]
since we're talking about magnus carlsen
we have to be complimentary in the intro
so
but we don't want to be repetitive
because i've started a lot of videos
already a certain way
hmm
i got you
ladies and gentlemen to become one of
the greatest chess players of all time
all elements of your game the opening
the middle game the end game tactics
strategy have to be complete
for magnus carlsen the end game is
oftentimes the difference between a win
a loss or a draw frequently when the
game is in its fourth fifth even
yeah i would get in trouble for watching
him during remote learning i would get
like a little notification
uh gotham chesses um i started streaming
and i would minimize my
school zoom class and head over there
and then mom would receive a text
message from levy
levy asking why i'm watching instead of
being on school
and then i got my butt kicked
d takes e5 d takes e5
okay so now we enjoy him being
kind of
celebrity
yeah so we're sometimes watching
his uh just
chess
commentaries plays i don't play chess i
have very little knowledge what i really
like is the way he commands again not
because he must grant some i really like
his style
got one more sub
so yeah it's uh it's 1 p.m on
september 18th
i'm at 1.16
antonio's also at 1.16 yeah when we do
pass we'll
share a bottle of wine but
i want that i want to be the first
channel the first chest channel like get
that diamond button man unfortunately
youtube only does it in in in logs so
it's only 100k a million and 10 million
i wish they made something for
five million but
a lot of people gifting tens appreciate
you all
what should we celebrate with
what's a good song
danger level just
yeah or maybe not oh did we cross it oh
we crossed it
oh my god oh and we're blowing past it
wow that came out of nowhere i thought i
thought you guys were going to make us
sit around but oh that was that was
awesome guys
[Music]
what it stands
no oh
mildly love it
a a sport or an activity
permanently associated with
you is
unbelievable and
how many people you helped reconnect
with their grandfather for example to
play chess when their grandfather was an
old age or how many people you helped
through a mental health crisis you
can have a big picture goal
but at the end of the day if you have
you cannot just go a b to that goal you
got to go a b
uh and and by the way it's not even c d
e f g h it's like a b g back to
uh c sometimes and you go all the way
there and come back and you gotta do a
again because you're struggling
so
uh success is incremental
one
point
one point one seven one point one
[Music]
two million
huh
[Music]
you